bonjour
alors c'était c'était la semaine la
confiance de l'espoir une portance avait
mal commencé à l'est les funérailles
nationales de jean marc ayrault un vrai
avec valls qui a prononcé cette oraison
funèbre qui restera célèbre sort d'ici
jean marc ayrault avec ton billet pour
nantes
valls a été étonnant enfin jab première
étape il a obtenu le vote de confiance
de la majorité même la moitié des verts
a voté la confiance c'est normal comme
il y avait aucun revers au gouvernement
ça les a rassurés
[Applaudissements]
à dire que manuel sont rixe et qui sait
parler même aux gens qui sont pas de son
bord il est monté à la tribune tel un
torero des arabes et il a dit ramires
police française est là avec une intro
pareil tout le monde s'est couché quoi
il a dit ça mais marion maréchal gilbert
collard ils sont là ils sont sur ce
texte ont fait une quenelle longue liste
d'approbations pas c'était un discours
d'une beauté du botté je vous promet du
sang des larmes de la douleur mais quand
même à la fin le régime crétois
c'était ben c'est le principe du
discours politique générale c'est le
viagra de la politique française ça
excite la personne qui en prend ça
secoue la personne qui le subit et trois
heures plus tard tout le monde a oublié
avec qu'il avait couché
et à la fin il y va t
il à dire quels pays comme la france
peut permettre un étranger de devenir
premier ministre
là je me suis dit c'est vrai c'est
tellement triste
manque justement que dans ce pays les
plus grands patriotes soit des mecs
naturalisé enfin moi c'est toujours
comme ça le naturaliser c'est comme les
nouveaux convertis comme ils sont
complexés d'avoir poussé hors sol ils
ont toujours qui rajoute une couche
photo genre qu'ils soient plus alors la
question c'est est ce qu'on peut lui
faire confiance à ramirez parce que la
france c'est pas une cage d'escalier
m'sieurs-dames non non non c'est autre
chose alors ma nuit moi cette technique
je la connais il va frapper à la porte
avec ses petites valises vers paix de
province va glisser son pied sous les
enseignes zara le pied dans l'embrasure
comme ça une autre a monté sa petite
tableau et la bam le show qui peut
commencer ramires police française
démonstrateur de relance de la
république et je vous présente ici la
machine à libérer de l'énergie a donné
du souffle regardez monsieur d'amour
chat chose muchachas blank aux banques
et à s' est tout de suite cette petite
merveille que j'ai nommé le bullshit du
communicant c'est moi regardez bien je
prends un chômeur je rappe je couche de
sécurité une formation je diminue ses
charges sur le smic n'augmente à -cg tu
tapes sur l'épaule lui courage enfin le
chômage c'est pas verdun non plus et bam
je le fais rire et pour le rassurer
j'ajoute non pas un non pas deux mais
trois à rome de toutes les robes
et à quoi ça sert mais ça sert à rien et
ça fait plaisir approché mais je n'ai
pas peur ramirez et maintenant oui je
vois ma voix vous demander ce qu'on voit
ici c'est un petit trou oui madame c'est
un déficit qui seront dès lors vous dire
allez y mettez le doigt juste bien sûr
servez vous alors je lui dit qu'est ce
que je vais faire à ce titre moi je
prends ce petit trou je tamponne avec un
peu de nationalisme je rajoute
montebourg qui fait le quai une pincée
de l'euro je t'emmerde est trop fort ça
pèse sur les exportations je sais c'est
gratuit ça mange pas là bas et ça fait
toujours plaisir les îles d'hawaï
arrière trop m'étaler grand bien sûr ça
fait plaisir madame est gourmand
et j'étais jour le même déficit j'ai
rien dit du tout mais c'est ludique faut
s'amuser or la petite fille comment il
s'appelle jennifer ces slovaques j'adore
et tout ce que je dis je le fais et ce
que je fais je le dis pour en 2027 aaa
et je vois monsieur qui hochent la tête
il n'a pas l'air convaincu que je compte
tout ça dans dix ans il appelle alors
qu'est ce que ça peut le faire plus
d'heures là on est à 4 % de déficit donc
c'est con mais s'amuser pour pimenter la
chose jeune type à 4 je ne dis pas ça
jeudi 10 % de déficit et baic ce déficit
a dit bon sang qu'est ce que je fais je
monte les impôts pas de simples pas de
30 mai 2 950% et là j'ai quoi j'ai des
français dans la rue un printemps social
débuté sur l'assemblée contre les
premiers ministres olemps carbonisés et
moi je suis élu ne me remerciez pas
madame vous en voulez encore laissez moi
vous parler du pouvoir d'achat non ne
riez pas je prends non pas un non pas
deux mais un et rémy et demi que je
finance par des baisses de cotisations
familiales et je le déshabille paul joe
des abysses jacques gelé sodomise tous
les deux oui je les brûle et les valeurs
vous me direz vous avez raison madame la
république c'était valeur alors je
prends la république je la mets dans mon
shaker gens c'est un cocktail
républicain marianne on the rocks vous
l'a secoué qu'est ce que j'obtiens la
république française laïque chrétienne
catalan bretonne une et plurielle dans
le respect du droit coutumier de la
france de voltaire frank leith de droit
divin fille aînée de l'église unie de
cacher ou une madame ramires police
française et puis sida
[Applaudissements]
et puis soudain soudas le dérapage il
souhaite diminuer le nombre de régions
et fuse donné certaines régions alors la
guadeloupe avec l'alsace ça me dérange
pas c'est logique
mais la haute et la basse normandie
enfin on est où peu de bon sens cc la
portée du premier venu de voir que
trouville et deauville c'est pas la même
chose d'ailleurs sur fusionner ces deux
communes ça s'appellerait commenté la
ville en ce moment
enfin comme dirait jean michel guérini
un peu d'honnêteté intellectuelle
c'est énorme et ses conneries diminuer
le nombre de régions au contraire faut
augmenter le nombre de régions faut
faire la haute normandie occidentale la
haute-normandie méridionale la
basse-normandie orientale la france
manuel ses mosaïques il ya une histoire
peut pas faire n'importe quoi par
exemple à paris si les bretons n'ont
aucun problème à se concentrer près de
la gare montparnasse il y aura sans
doute jamais de quartiers juifs près de
la gare de l'est
non
bref
bonne nouvelle bien évidemment la
nomination d'harlem désir les
socialistes sont rassurés qu'ils ne
soient plus au ps couler la france ok
mais pas le parti
comme disait un proche de françois
hollande on est quand même des gens
responsables alors pas belle la vie et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux